we had a few interesting questions on
the difficult video so let's explore a
little bit more about what we can do of
difficult and what we can't do or
shouldn't do with diffie-hellman so
let's talk about man-in-the-middle
attacks and how they're a real problem
for diffie-hellman when it's used on its
own and that's where we bring in RSA or
public key encryption to help us we
won't go over too much of difficult ghin
right plenty of videos on that already
but let's remember we've got good ol
Alice and Bob and we have some shared
parameters already so a generator G and
a large prime number n and they're going
to share some information and calculate
a shared key so Alice is going to
generate a private value a Bob is going
to generate a private value B they're
going to share and I'm going to simplify
the notation you know a lot here too so
we don't spend ages writing it out but
Alice broadly speaking will send Bob G ^
a like this so G ^ a and Bob will send g
^ b and they use that both calculate G
to the a B all modern it's a G to the a
a B for what this allows us to do is
share two values in public and use them
to calculate with our private value
something no one else can do right
that's really helpful but what this
doesn't do is provide any protection
from someone sitting in the middle here
and intercepting these messages so let's
look at a different version of this
where there's someone nefarious in the
middle let's call him Shawn so same
again Alice and Bob and now we have
Shawn sitting in the middle now Shawn
has control of this network that's the
issue right so you can not only read the
message but you can also intercept
messages transmit messages again you
know this kind of stuff so let's say
you're a rogue admin or something like
this so Alice produces her value a right
so maybe bob is a server maybe bob is a
shop and Alice's our client so she's
going to send the initial message that
says I'd like to talk to you let's
establish a shared secret so alice is
going to calculate G to the a and send
it off to Bob now Shawn doesn't let her
through that's the problem Shawn
intercepts that message and stops it and
pretends to be Bob from then on
so Shawn comes in here and goes oh yes
I'm Bob right and he isn't so he
a private key s and a value G to the s
and sends it back and as far as Alice
knows this is Jesus yeah there's nothing
in here but says this is particularly
Sean Bob could have generated the same
we're calling s but it's just a number
it could have been projected by anyone
so he sends its back they perform a
normal key exchange and they end up with
G to the a s so Sean has now an
established shared secret with Alice so
far so good
now Sean then there knows that Alice
wanted to talk to Bob originally so then
Sean says my name's Alice can i
establish a shared secret with you so
Sean sends G to the S over to Bob and
Bob goes are brilliant and sends off G
to the B back to Sean and they establish
a shared secret G to the s B or at BS or
we know whatever right G to the s be
what Sean has done by sticking himself
in the middle here is calculate two
different keys both of which he knows
and he can then use him to intersect
every single message then between Alice
and Bob so Alice then sends some actual
HTTP traffic or something like this
encrypted with a key derive from this
Sean can immediately decrypt it
re-encrypt it with s be send it off to
Bob and essentially act as a man in the
middle of every step
so every time a message is sent decrypt
it read it do whatever you want change
it we encrypt it and send it on this is
a huge problem because diffie-hellman
provides no way of stopping this that's
not what it's designed for it's designed
for two parties I suppose that trust
each other to generate a shared secret
if you start throwing other people into
it the whole thing breaks this is where
RSA and other public key crypto graphic
schemes come in and rescue us to me
straightaway diffie-hellman it's dead in
the water if he was in real trouble here
but luckily it isn't the only public key
protocol we've got so this is what RSA
does let's imagine that Bob is a server
so he has a public key and a private key
associate let's say RSA or DSA it's not
important so we have Alice and Bob again
I'm going to get tired of naming these I
should have just put a and B Bob has a
private key and a public key so remember
that back to the video that Rob did on
in private key and the things we
discussed in the past anything you
encrypt with key a can only being
decrypted with key be like I'm wanna cry
and so on the public key is given out
freely it's not probably on Bob's
certificate the private key he holds
back so this time Alice wants to talk to
Bob what we want to do is assure that no
one is sitting in the middle of this
conversation also as it happens we'd
quite like for Bob to verify his
identity because we want to make sure we
trust his server so we can bring that in
as well Alice sends G to the a over to
Bob just as normal we're assuming but
the generator in the and the prime
number already been established we're
not worrying about this Bob it's going
to send over G to B but to stop anyone
from sitting in the middle he's going to
bring his private key and make sure that
Alice knows only he could have sent that
message he sends G to the B as well as a
hash of this message or a digital
signature of his message signed with his
private key which would be you know
something like a hash of G to the B
that's too many brackets and then all
signed by K private so if he signed it
with his private key the only thing that
can decrypt that make sense of it is his
public yes that's right
so what Alice will do is something
called a signature verification so she
will take G to be perform the exact same
process and then apply the public key to
his encrypted version and see if they
match and if they do
she knows that only he could have done
that because only he has the private key
this is assuming he hasn't given the
private key away we hope we like to make
that assumption of where their food
breaks what he does by sending this over
is Alice still get G to the B like she
did before but she can combine a very to
get G to the a B but Shawn or any other
anyone else in the Paris I when the
first people are available if they try
and use a different value they won't be
able to sign it with the private key
that Bob had if they can that that's a
real problem but they can't so Bob is
able to send a message to Alice but not
only shares his difficult parameter
which is something that needs to be done
anyway as part of the key exchange but
also sign it to ensure that only he
could have send that message now this is
this is a fundamental part of a numerous
internet key exchanges so the i ke
protocol that's used in VPNs and the
handshake using TLS or anytime you see
HTTPS this is the kind of thing you're
going to
I mean in fact if we go to a standard
website this is Google Chrome's security
overview that is telling us what the
handshaking TLS establishes as a cipher
suite for our communication with this
server and you can see we're using TLS
1.2 elliptic curve diffie-hellman and
RSA so we're not using diffie-hellman
key by native RSA in this kind of
mechanism such that no one can be a
man-in-the-middle and intercept our
messages and interfere with them it does
sound like we are potentially over
complicating this I mean if we've got
RSA why do we need diffie-hellman yeah
you're right so technically speaking we
don't technically speaking we can use
RSA in let's say a TLS handshake and
historically that's what's been done so
what would happen in that situation is
Alice would generate a shared key and
encrypt it with Bob's public key so I
took that way she knew only Bob could
ever read that secret key and then
they'd carry on the conversation the the
issue is one of something called perfect
forward secrecy so the problem is that
if you did this if you if you used only
RSA ever to perform encryption right
then if anyone ever breaks that RSA key
or hacks into deserve and obtains it or
heartbleed turns up and gives it away
then someone who's been recording
messages between the two suddenly can
decrypt everything they could maybe to
go for all the handshakes so they can
decrypt that symmetric key every time
and decrypt every single historic
message has been sent between Alice and
Bob
so diffie-hellman is are more of a kind
of per session deal yeah diffie-hellman
RSA keys have established and DSA keys
were established over a long period of
time let's say one or two years and to
save us a real problem if they get
broken we don't tend to use that for the
actual encryption what we tend to do is
generate something called an ephemeral
diffie-hellman key if ephemeral meaning
we do it pretty much every time and we
generally we actually use them to
generate the shared secret and we use
RSA to provide this authenticity all
right so it's a combination of both
diffie-hellman gets us a very quick way
to establish a shared secret but it's
only used a few times RSA gives us a way
of verifying Bob's identity and making
sure there isn't a man in the middle
and we don't tend to use RSA anyway for
long term encryption because it's too
slow for a whole message so that's why
we'd use it to derive symmetric keys and
use something like AAS which is much
much faster
and this prime is 2048 bits so our
private key is going to be sum this is
our a and this here is our G to the a
mod n and they're roughly roughly the
same size this will be slightly smaller